the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe has
pretty much been built around the
Infinity stones often called infinity
gems and the comics these mystic
super-powered baubles have shown up in
almost every Marvel Cinematic Universe
film to date and it's all been leading
to infinity war these powerful little
rocks are the power to completely
destroy the entire Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Marvel fans have seen big
bad fan OHS planning to get his hands on
them since the first Avengers film
everything climaxes in Avengers infinity
war when he shows up just to take them
all for himself
as the comics predicted but where
exactly are the Infinity stones in the
MCU we've encountered most of them
already and it isn't hard to surmise
where in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
arrests might be scattered here's a full
rundown of where we can find all of the
MCS Infinity stones leading up to
Avengers infinity war the mine stone
Loki used the mine stone in a scepter to
great effect in the Avengers
brainwashing folks to do his bidding
along the way Earth's Mightiest Heroes
spend the early part of Avengers age of
Ultron tracking it down from hydras
control
Ultron stole it and bedded it in his
potential new body but his plans went
south and her body was stolen by the
good guys finally team Stark tapped into
its power to activate the powerful new
hero vision to help defeat Ultron the
mine stone it's one of the six Infinity
stones the greatest power in the
universe unparalleled in its destructive
capability one side effect of that
creation process the mine stone is stuck
in visions forehead it's what gives him
his immense power and there's no way to
get it out without something really
really bad happening when last we left
vision at the end of 2016 s Captain
America Civil War he was serving the
official Avengers squad under the
leadership of Iron Man it stands to
reason this would be one of the easiest
stones for Thanos to find the ones he
lands in the middle of New York City
since they'll be attached to her face
that will be punching him in the head if
you need more than that footage from the
film's first trailer shows one of Thanos
minions making a move to pluck it out of
vision skull no word on exactly what
that will mean for vision but it's
probably not good news the space stone
the space stone has been kicking around
the MCU since Captain America the First
Avenger when it was being called the
tesseract and has been used by both the
Red Skull and Loki in their attempts at
world domination shield also held it for
a while to try and - capabilities for
super weapons after Thor Iron Man
the gang defeated Loki and the Avengers
the tesseract was shipped back to Asgard
for safekeeping inside Odin's vaults
which howls all kinds of powerful but
possibly inauthentic goodies let's go
Ferb that was the last place as
particular infinity stone was seen and
even though as god was destroyed down to
his foundations drawing for Ragnarok it
stands to reason it survived best guess
Loki was the last person in the vaults
so he almost certainly grabbed it before
sparking the match to burn Asgard to the
ground on Thor's orders the first
trailer for infinity war offers its own
clues showing Loki holding the tesseract
up for someone so if nothing else we
know he ends up with it somehow the time
stone the time stone was first
introduced to the MCU and Doctor Strange
as the eye of agamotto discovered among
the artifacts being held by the Masters
of the mystic arts strange uses it to
create a time loop to save the world
from the reality devouring Dormammu
outsmarting one of the Marvel Universe's
most dangerous entities but the stone
itself isn't without its dangers
temporal manipulations can create
branches in time unstable dimensional
openings spatial paradoxes time loops
despite the fact that he saved the world
strange is still learning the ropes when
it comes to the mystic arts so the time
stone was put back in the hands of the
Masters of the mystic arts and is likely
being stored at karma taja in Katmandu
Nepal when Thanos had never tably
attacks it would make sense for him to
come after the stone perhaps dr. strange
alarm up with the AI as he heads into
battle with the mad Titan regardless
like the mine stone that infinity stone
is already on earth and should make for
an easy target for Thanos the reality
stone the Chain of Custody and the
reality stone is a bit harder to track
than the rest of the MCS Infinity stones
first introduced in Thor the dark world
is extremely powerful ether sought after
by Malekith the reality stone was
eventually recovered by Thor by the end
of the film once the Dark Elves were
vanquished
after that the mid-credits scene in the
dark world revealed the Asgardians
decided to hand the stone off to the
collector for safekeeping because of the
dangers of keeping two stones in the
same place one
down
[Music]
five to go the collectors home are
nowhere was eventually destroyed in
guardians of the galaxy though it stands
to reason he dug the reality stone out
of the rubble and distill in possession
of a at this point that's assuming he
hasn't simply sold it off to fan OHS in
the meantime of course the power stone
most Marvel movies revolve around
powerful MacGuffins but Fury's powerful
is that mysterious orb everyone is
fighting over in the first guardians of
the galaxy that world is destroying
Orbis a Power Stone which Peter quill
tracks down on a planet joined the
film's opening scenes Road in the
accuser later attempts to use it to wipe
sander off the map will eventually
requires it and holds hands for the rest
of his team and uses its power to take
out Ronan once and for all once the
battle was won we all handed the Power
Stone over to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping on Xandar assuming it hadn't
wandered off to another spot in the MCU
balance will probably have to wage war
against the entire intergalactic police
force to get his hands on his particular
infinity stone the soul stone the first
few phases of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe have done most of the heavy
lifting introducing the majority of the
Infinity stones but one mystery remains
the soul stone the mysterious final
stone has yet to be formally introduced
in the MCU though there are a few
theories guardians of the galaxy volume
2 has already planted the seed for Adam
warlocks introduction and the soul stone
is intimately connected to his origin
story in the comics so if Marvel wanted
to bring that character into the fold
ahead of Guardians volume 3 it makes for
a convenient outlet the most likely
option though seems to be black panther
the land of Wakanda is the most
technologically advanced on the planet
and is an extremely spiritual place to
the point we see black panther actually
traveled to the spirit realm to confirm
of his late father looking to the
footage we've seen of infinity war where
Condor seems to factor in heavily to the
point we see a full wakandan army
charging into battle could work on to be
in possession of the final Infinity
stone and that charge is the nation's
battle to keep it from falling into
Thanos his hands it makes a lot of sense
and give Black Panther real stakes and
follows his assault the gauntlets
all of the MC use Infinity stones have
to fit together somehow and that's where
the Infinity Gauntlet comes in it's
designed to hold them all and give the
wearer practically godlike powers and
Pharaohs has a leg up on the competition
the post-credits scene of avengers age
of ultron showed
Pano's wearing a stone this gauntlet he
only needs to gather the stones with
infinity war rolls around as keynote
fans are likely also aware the Infinity
Gauntlet was previously shown all the
way back in 2011 slaw when it was
featured in the background of Odin's
vaults
it created a continuity problem when
Singh started barreling toward an
eventual war with Thanos
so thor ragnarok a cleverly retcon that
gauntlet Odin's treasure fake fake it
made for a fun joke but also cleaned up
a mess you plot thread that have been
left dangling since 2011 Infinity stones
assembled promo art action figures and
early footage from Avengers infinity war
shows Stannis in possession of all the
Infinity stones in the MCU which doesn't
bode well for Earth's Mightiest Heroes
if the MCU gauntlet has a power set
similar to the ones in the comics all
the heroes in the MCU will have their
hands full stopping fan oohs it allows
the wearer to manipulate time and change
the past manipulate space and matter and
basically rewrite reality itself on a
whim which means Santos is about to make
the Avengers and their friends lives
very very difficult
let's go thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your left team
[Music]